welcome back to uncensored live from New
York City as the race for the White
House officially gets
underway well voters across the
Midwestern State of Iowa will this
evening Brave very very cold
temperatures maybe the coldest ever for
Iowa caucus to select their Republican
candidate former president Donald Trump
is expected to crush the field with
potentially as much as 50% of the vote
which will be an all-time record but can
it be stopped and other polls wrong
joining me now in the studio former
conservative MP Louise mentioned
journalist Emily Austin and plal
strategist and pster Frank Lance is in
Iowa before we go to Frank who's
probably freezing to slow uh Extinction
over there in Iowa let's come just
quickly to Emily and Lise just get a
reaction to that interview with Thomas
hand with his daughter that I was struck
by how she wanted to be there with him
she never stopped stroking his face
particularly when he cried or got angry
really powerful there are some Fates
worse than death and what you saw there
was a father looking down the barrel at
what could have happened to his little
girl and I think when people forget what
actually happened what kicked off this
entire War they're forgetting that these
terrorists took a little girl hostage
and put her father through that and she
was one of the lucky ones horrible to
say but some 13-year-old girls didn't
Faire as well as that poor little child
there still a baby missing now we've no
idea really what's happened to that baby
or countless other people Emily what did
you make of it I just remember grieving
along with the most of the world when we
thought Emily was dead and then
celebrating when we found out she's
alive but still don't really know her
fate and to watch like you just said
watching her comfort her dad when she's
the one who went through the trauma as
well as he um just shows you the
resilience of kids and like it's sad to
say she's too young to remember but we
were discussing in The Green Room this
is something that's going to haunt her
for life and it's you know I sent him a
text just now saying getting an amazing
reaction to that interview Thomas and I
said you are an extraordinary man and he
replied I I'm not I'm just an ordinary
person trying to deal with this like
everybody else which I thought was
typically modest of him but actually
he's right you know these were just
ordinary people living in the Kuts we
didn't know who they were and now
forever they will be part of the history
of this horror that's been unfurling um
let me go to to to Frank um Frank let's
let's segue into the election in uh Iowa
where it all kicks off for real I've
going to say as a Brit from across the
pond it always seems a bit weird you
sist
that so much seems to hinge on Iowa and
the strange way they do this sell it to
me well I'm not going to sell it to you
I actually want to hearken back to that
interview I've had the chance to listen
to the last 10 minutes of it and it
makes me angry at the politicians over
here in America tearing each other apart
over nothing insulting each other being
rude and abusive that surely when we see
these crises that are happening in other
parts of the globe why we must behave
like idiots and how bad it makes America
look so no I don't want to sell Iowa I
do want to say that Iowa voters are more
sophisticated than average they take the
responsibilities very seriously they do
care about the outcome Donald Trump is
likely to get about half the vote the
big question is who comes in second
because that individual gets bragging
rights for the state that really matters
New Hampshire uh appear Iowa makes a
statement New Hampshire makes a
difference and it's just a shame that
the statement is being made in weather
that's 15 degrees below
zero that presumably will help Trump
simply because if you look at all the
polling yes Nikki Haley's got a bit of
momentum and replaced uh DeSantis into
second place but if you get into the
weeds of the of the data the uh sort of
very positive enthusiasm for candidates
Trump roaring ahead at nearly 90% the
santis second Nikki pretty low on
enthusiasm if actually it comes down to
who's going to get out of their warm
comfortable home and go and vote in
these conditions you've got to think it
helps Trump and may actually help the
santis a
bit well it it I think it might hurt
Trump because his vote is pretty old and
if you're over 75 going out in this
weather is actually dangerous for you
and I think it hurts the vake ramaswami
because even though he's hasn't been
talked about as much his vote is 18 to
29 year olds and they're less like to
vote in the end Trump is going to win
big whether he crosses that 50%
threshold we don't know the votes have
to be counted but also in the end it's
amazing to me that Donald Trump in most
surveys is leading Joe Biden even though
Trump has been indicted 91 times even
though he's been thrown off at two
ballots even though the campaign against
him has been so vicious because he
himself has turned himself into a victim
into to someone who's not prosecuted but
persecuted and right now you have to
give Trump the narrow advantage in
November despite the primaries and
caucuses and all this chaos that's
around American politics yeah it's it's
quite extraordinary it's unprecedented
Emily I want to play a little clip this
is a Donald Trump last night trying to
get his vote out and making a typical
Trump
remark you can't sit
home if you're sick as a dog you say
darling I got
even if you vote and then pass away it's
worth
it now look we're all laughing right and
that's the reaction I watched this my
old CNN colleagues trying to be serious
about this and I couldn't help
themselves but laughing this Emily is
his trump card literally is that he is
funnier than the other candidates and as
we've seen with Boris Johnson in the UK
who became prime minister if you've got
a sense of humor and you don't talk or
behave like other politicians you can go
a long way and you can make a comeback
like Trump yeah I mean being being 22
years old in gen Z's epitome I I grew up
in a trump election 2016 was the first
election I can recall Trump won that
2020 Trump participated lost but being
gen Z I grew up watching Trump and to me
it was always just yes he says it as he
pleases and he doesn't really think
twice before speaking which is a
blessing and a curse you get the
transparency but you also sometimes need
a filter especially on a global stage
and I think it comes down to a balance
the famous quote to be loved or to be
feared now internationally you have to
be feared otherwise you risk being taken
advantage of and being a vulnerable
country which America is very vulnerable
right now but at the same time you risk
Trump winning might you know even prompt
a civil war within America which nobody
benefits from of course the other great
Advantage Trump has and why we may be
seeing this extraordinary comeback is
that Biden looks so weak record low
approval ratings again this week and
they're already terrible um a lot of
democrat two-thirds of them don't think
you should run again but he is and if he
does you got to think Trump has a great
chance I don't think Trump has a great
chance honestly I don't think polls this
far out for the general election mean
very much we've seen it over and over
again that said Joe Biden should not
make Hillary Clinton's mistake and start
being complacent in 2020 Joe Biden won
because he wasn't Trump time for a
change is the most effective slogan in
politics all the time forever now it's
time for a change from Biden so he's got
to be careful he's got to be cautious
the Democrats the White House will be
looking at the results of this caucus
with with great interest very great
interest is the race for second place
only Nikki Haley has really managed
expectations she said that New
Hampshire's her big state if she manages
to outperform she could get a bit of a
mention just in case the Supreme Court
throws a monkey wrench into Donald
Trump's all right Frank Lun no one knows
about polling better than you uh what
what are the possible scenarios here
could we see one maybe two two
candidates dropping out by the time
Iowa's come out on the
wash absolutely Ronda sandis cannot
justify continuing after spending more
than a hundred million and most of that
here in Iowa if he comes in third I
can't imagine him going Beyond tomorrow
and then you also have the look of aake
ramaswami who's self-funding his
campaign does he get over 10% of the
votes which indicates that there's still
some rationale for his campaign and then
you have ASA Hutchinson who most Brits
will never heard of because most
Americans have never heard of him he's a
former Governor successful Governor at
that and no one he's getting zero point
or I should say not 7% of the vote uh
once again I agree with with your
colleague that you don't trust the
polling this early in the campaign but
make no mistake it's going to be more
negative than it's ever been it's going
to be more personal more vicious and
more Americans are going to say to hell
with American politics and American
elections as the months continue okay
prediction time what's going to happen
here Emily I politely disagree with you
because I don't think Biden's given
Americans enough of an incentive to vote
for him again Biden wins it's purely out
of I think if it's Biden Trump trump
wins me too I think Trump and I wouldn't
have said that a year ago but You' got
to say the guy's resilient I will say
with Trump he has the thinnest skin of
any human being I've met in my life he
reacts he reacts to everything right uh
but he has the thickest he can soak up
stuff that would crush any other
politician and Louise you've been a
politician if you've got that thick skin
like Trump and you can SWAT away all the
buzzards and the Flies you've got a
great chance people like always like a
political candidate who just speaks his
mind and doesn't give a damn I know
you're not a big fan of Boris Johnson
but he had that quality Trump has that
quality he was obviously joking when he
said you know go out and die for me to
vote the fact is he's I think that Biden
will beat Trump quite handily but I
think Trump is the only candidate that
Biden could could beat let's go quickly
back to Frank before he literally
freezes to death in front of us Frank if
it's Biden Trump can you see a away
Biden
wins well I want to separate Donald
Trump from Boris Johnson Boris has
written more books than Donald Trump has
read I believe that the election is way
too that the election is way too close
to call that either candidate can win if
you force to bend on it now I would bet
that Donald Trump would come out
slightly ahead because his voters are
passionate yeah they
are